le plus dur au cinéma c'est de porter
les boîtes jean luc godard
[Musique]
jean luc godard bonsoir bonsoir alors le
30 décembre les français vont découvrir
aux deux derniers films soigne ta droite
oui il ya une chose déjà qui est très
étonnante dans le film j'ai adoré une
chose qui est très étonnant c'est un
générique est un peu dans l'esprit de ce
que faisait sacha guitry
répondant aux dés
avec madame laval en partie de l'argent
à l'abri oui oui oui les tricks est
partie d'une équipe j'appelle la bande
des quatre qui étaient pagnol cocteau
guitry et du reims qui a toujours choqué
beaucoup marguerite quand je la mène ces
trois là on dit toujours dans les films
de godard les jambons quand dans les
projections privées l'autre soir là ils
sont un peu bon ils savent pas trop quoi
dire mais quand les spectateurs sortent
un single j'ai compris j'ai pas compris
moi je crois que rien comprendre dans le
film je crois que il suffit de regarder
alors ce que j'ai vu disons plus et à
comprendre mais il y aller
qu'est ce qu'on appelle comprendre c'est
pas grave on comprend pas forcément tout
tout de suite en particulier la
la musique enfin c'est très très musical
pas seulement parce qu'aller mitsouko
mais il faut pour prendre avant de
comprendre je peux vous dire ce que j'ai
vu ah oui volontiers
le puits la mère de celle ci elle avait
perdu entendu donc le ciel de vous
montrer le ciel très simplement avec les
avions à réaction comme ça qu'ils
passaient un moment il ya un barbelé qui
est net qui devient flou parce que de
changer le point ma salvini tout un lot
et ça devient une étoile oui il ya le
ciel des pieds à la terre et là je dois
dire c'est extraordinaire c'est à dire
que du sel moi qui me rappelle un peu ce
que vous aviez s'aidant d'un week-end ou
quand je monte dans un avion c'est ce
que je vois dans votre avion c'est à
dire des gens sont exactement comme ça
moi je les vois comme ça dans l'avion
donc c'est pour ça que ça m'a beaucoup
plu il ya un vieux monsieur très riche
qui apprend à une jeune fille et pauline
lafont a joué au golf et c'est assez
dégoûtant on comprend plein de choses
derrière on imagine ce qui peut se
passer quand quand ils sont tous les
deux au restaurant où ils ont rien à se
dire et quand ils sont au lit ou où elle
doit pas avoir vraiment envie ce lecerf
je sais pas peut-être que je fantasme il
ya le et l2 stade du heysel est assez
terrible et puis au début vous faites
wimbledon aussi fait tout seul wimbledon
quand ça c'est la terre et ça rejoint la
chanson du mitsouko qui ne jouent pas
d'ailleurs dans le film il ya que les
premiers accords on les voit travaillons
et va chercher et la chanson n'est
mitsouko sais c'est comme ça
effectivement quand c'est le ciel c'est
le ciel et quand c'est la terre c'est
comme ça ça vous va comme ça va moi je
pense à la firme qui zappe tout seul
c'est à dire que c'est comme si on était
devant un poste de télé qui qu'on
s'appelle comme ça sauf qu'au bout d'un
moment il ya une cohérence ci serait pas
vous attend dans le cas si on faisait ça
avec un sabre devant un poste de télé
évidemment une cohérence qui se créent
comme ça et on en sort avec une heure on
sort changer
ma mère si non c'est vrai parce que moi
j'avais passé la journée au montage
maintenant que ça va le voir
alors d'une phrase qui est très drôle
dans le film c'est quand vous dites au
cinéma le plus dur c'est de porter les
boîtes c'est vrai j'en ai pas mal porté
et des moments je me suis mis à la vidéo
je peux citer - le oui
alors le film a coûté combien
entre 3 et 6 millions le budget qui on
doit donner à son cutter comme vous
savez le cinéma est sous tutelle du
centre du cinéma et du ministère de la
culture donc on doit rendre les comptes
et je crois qu'il a dû les comptes
finaux sont à peu près 6 millions 6
millions alors ces deux fois trop cher
vous avez déclaré un jour dans un
journal que de toute façon le un budget
comme ça cela correspond à un salaire de
6 7 mille francs par mois actuellement
les gens devraient pas se plaindre de
gagner 6 est qu'ils feront pas moi qu'on
peut quand même se débrouiller avec ça
c'est pas tout à fait assez pas tout à
fait assez surtout qu'on dépense
je crois que si les gens pouvaient
dépasser leur temps si on peut lire il
aurait les français essayent dur et
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont eu ma vie la
vie des japonais et des albanais et que
je respecte de ce point de vue là
trouver quelque chose d'intéressant dans
l'industrie française qui essaye de
dépasser son temps et fabriquer une
voiture
trois fois plus lentement qu'un allemand
je trouve ya il ya quelque chose de bien
là dedans c'est votre côté suisse d'être
devenu un bon de donner un bon
producteur au niveau pognon vous
débrouillez bien maintenant bon charge
de gens qui osent
enfin vous savez bien vous savez non non
non c'est pas je sais j'essaye de me
vendre l'édifice vous arrivez à les
monter tous ces films quand même c'est
pas d'énorme succès commerciaux vous
avez quand même allez montez allait les
faire aboutir puisqu'on aime paris 1,6
million
à nous c'est énorme c'est énorme
c'était non mais j'ai découvert j'ai mis
beaucoup de temps que
le principal c'est comme un petit
entrepreneur c'est d'arriver à gérer
soi-même et d'être libre de ça je veux
dire mon je me souviens que mon père
quand on souvent lui demandait de
l'argent il ya qu'est ce qu'il veut en
faire c'était foutu
vous avez des problèmes et que les
acteurs sur ce film je vivrai s'est pas
très bien passé - si la ville mais
c'était beaucoup plus difficile aussi et
souvent les acteurs bonson un côté ils
sont là ils sont là ils sont là il faut
vivre aussi on a et c'est difficile donc
il ya quelqu'un pendant un an
quand il d'abord ça finit par coûter
trop cher même si 1000 francs par mois
donc c'est difficile c'est ce problème
effectivement de moi je fais des romans
un bon roman ça demande quand même trois
ou quatre ans à faire
alors on peut passer ça la difficulté le
charbo si les vannes ont ça s'est bien
passé je l' ai très peu utilisé j'ai
trop peu utilisé je vais passer des
moments peut-être je peux dire je
referai mais c'est difficile parce
qu'ils sont pas disponibles vous êtes
génial quand elles sont de vraies
vérités munitions peu dans votre psy et
puis quelle chanson il ne joue pas à moi
je trouve ça drôle mais savez c'est
frustrant pour les gens quand même
je ne crois pas car ça voilà sion ont
leur les voiles à trouver on les voit la
chaire en mai - après la menace même pas
je pense qu'on les voit l'enfance et
l'enfant- l'enfant t il jouer mais en
fait c'est l'amour et après c'est le
résultat ça m'intéresse moins en guinée
où le disque existe pourquoi refaire ce
qui existe on disait que l'angleterre
était le plus court des suisses
prochinois alors le cinéma mondial on
peut dire sans flagornerie a eu avant
godard et après godard un peu comme il
ya eu avant orson welles est la preuve
ce noël d'accord là dessus non non pas
refuser tout cas c'est d'aller tous
rendus possibles
on a dit et on a fait et on a montré je
crois encore aujourd'hui que le possible
peut exister ouvert vous avez ouvert des
chemins que qui est inimaginable avant
non mais qu'un chemin peut s'ouvrir non
celui même pas là ouvert ouvrir un
chemin c'est déjà
vous pensez que vous allez changer quoi
dans le cinéma
rien ils peuvent pas dire des trucs
pareils
non c'est d'eux
que c'est possible que
que quelque chose est toujours possible
où qu'on soit avec une certaine foi
qu'il faut travailler et que c'est
possible y'a pas
c'est possible c'est un peu comme plus
qu'un seul possible fait partie de la
possible et probable si vous voulez et
qu'il est probable que le possible va va
être mais pas impossible
c'est un peu picasso peinture non
c'est un tellement grand exemple
et que je crois que j'ai surtout
travaillé et qu'on est responsable vale
vale enfin moi en particulier mais sur
le fond que que finalement on rendait
compte effectivement que on s'adresse à
la partie du spectateur - en particulier
maintenant je m'en rends compte
consciemment à la partie qui est metteur
en scène de sa propre vie et que
peut-être on lui dit d'une manière
métaphorique parce que ce n'est qu'un
ensemble d'image que ta propre vie est
possible à vivre puisque moi je suis
arrivé à faire un film voilà vous il ya
des gens qui sont déçus quand même
son cinéma depuis ce qui m'ennuie parce
qu'ils disent tout le temps à l'époque
mais pierrot le fou c'est génial comme
il n'aime pas les herbes folles de
pérols fabre c'est l'affairé de la
liste est mieux avant où c'était comme
ça pierrot le fou est un film très très
riche aussi de ce point de vue là c'est
filmé un son plus pop ou si on est
relativement à l'époque vous aviez plus
d'argent non pas de tous non ils ont
tous coûté ce prix là où je goûtais peu
près ce qu'il a mais il y en a des fois
qu'ils avaient plus de paillettes et
peut-être un poster et surtout à
postériori parce qu'à l'époque il a fait
120 demi d'entrées ce qui était pas oui
c'est cette veille de grands succès
commerciaux sauf le premier film et la
crise du cinéma alors vous en pensez
quoi il y en avait sept vies en aval y
en a jamais eu il ya un peu un état de
crise en france
et qui est très typique à la france qui
est un pays à l'état de crise dans
l'industrie française et le cinéma qui
est le
qu'on pourrait dire le joyau de cette
industrie qui est en déclin ainsi ni
maladie c'est un signe qu'il ya quelque
chose qui la france ne sait pas très
bien je passe les français savent pas
s'ils sont un grand peuple s'ils sont
bêtes ils se vivent son cinéma non non
non pas du tout si son
jeu pas ils gagnent moins d'argent que
les allemands et travaille moins bien
que les japonais
ils savent pas qu'ils sont le cinéma
on a le mal en france a disparu l'usap
riant qu'il le croisait rang l'italie a
vu le cinéma je les paie s'il y en a
mais les français ont toujours vu voulu
faire autant de films que les amériques
les américains ils ont 250 millions
d'habitants la largeur du pays qu'on
connaît on ne peut pas faire autant de
films en france le seul moment où en
france le cinéma bien marché c'est
pendant l'occupation
60 films par an je le bureau période
c'est la meilleure période
il faut en tirer des conclusions ce
n'est pas mauvais des conversions de la
moitié était à l'étranger
l'autre partie du travail n 1 ont fait
la meilleure période hélas les
télévisions françaises qu'elles
ça aussi mais là la situation vous
faites sur ce qui vient de se passer là
depuis trois mois il n'empêche pas quels
rapports ils ont entre la télévision les
français ils en sont malades que ça soit
les gouvernements ou les téléspectateurs
ils en sont malades je sais pas pourquoi
il ya un signe de ce qu'est la culture
parce que je pensais la culture la télé
ou le cinéma transmettent pas de culture
la peinture non plus bon en fait on dit
c'est de la cuisse est pas vrai la
culture c'est la télévision la culture
c'est ça que ça vous et moi comme ça
plus ou moins bien éclairé bavardant
ouais mais c'est la culture d'autres
choses la culture c'est ce qui se mange
voulait que je vais vivre et je sais pas
et j'aime bien écrire
quand vous arrêterez de faire du cinéma
pas si vous si tenté que vous allez lire
avant que le cinéma vous aurez
non parce que là c'est trop difficile
finalement peut ne rien faire tout en
faisant quelque chose à partir de rien
comme ça et qui se fait il ya quelque
chose comme la création du monde chaque
fois du fait que c'est une imitation ch
a représenté qu'on vous reconnaît il ya
quelque chose qui est qu'il n'ya pas
avec la télévision qui transmet
simplement la télévision font rien nous
on travaille un peu enfin pas de choses
mais elles elles font rien une caméra de
télévision ne fout rien une caméra
cinéma n'est pas dans cet état là quand
même préféré caméras l'image
croyait plus
mais on devrait pas être là comme ça je
suis dit c'est ne voit pas être l'élite
nice c'était vous qui mettez en scène
comment
mais ça peut pas se dire comme ça il
faut répéter travailler avant voire et
après faire quelque chose peut-être si
votre émission et
et les publics comme vous l'avez dit
c'est peut-être que vous faites autre
chose que vous êtes peut être un des
rares animateurs peu ou pas du tout payé
et qui fait que ce que vous faites
ailleurs devient quelque chose ici lieu
de balancer un équilibre écologique
c'est mettre l'argent véritable et a
frôlé un spectateur le sens un petit peu
qu'ils sont
un jour paraître politique un peu
maintenant c'est comme j'ai créé un truc
un peu fou mais je trouve bon on sait
que vous avez toute une période comme ça
féministe marxiste léniniste propre
entre ménages depuis ma naissance
je viens même dû nous et quand décalé un
truc un peu fou a dit qu'israël c'est
une cellule cancéreuse en progression
provient des trucs comme ça mais il faut
pas dire il faut qu'on crée
il faut montrer et puis ensuite c'est
pas un jugement palanque si on regarde
les cartes de la guerre d'espagne la
progression on voit l'espagne on voit
une petite tache noire une petite tache
noire ici une petite tache noire en
catalogne une pizza et on voit les
taches noires qui grandit c'est ce que
des résultats devait les voilà c'est
tout ce que je dis d'accord si on voit
israël la création de l'état d'israël on
voit comme ça on dit ça et puis on alors
moi je dis mais qui leur a donné le
cancer
quand j'y vais c'est le goût c'est venu
parce que ça se transmet le cancer si
c'est le pen y avait un truc pareil ça
aurait été terrible comme quoi c'est un
problème est maintenant comme quoi ça
pourrait même être largué
finalement pas le godard d'y aller d'une
cellule cancéreuse tout le monde bon jeu
pour exister il faut marteler
je le dis pas je montre je monte et
après jeudi d'autres choses et il faut
regarder et puis on regarde qui leur a
fourni le cancer qu'est ce qui fait
qu'ils se battent que israël se bat
contre son frère qui est ismaël pourquoi
les palestiniens sont les seuls
gens de cet endroit là du même pays qui
ont qui sont contre tous les
gouvernements arabes contre tous qui
sont laïcs qui veut pas le problème de
religion
et donc s'étaler seul ami possible donc
quoi ce qu'on tape plus fort grâce à une
forme de cancer pourquoi ce que la
cellule cancéreuse attaque sa meilleure
amie
en biologie
et religieusement vous en mets tout
je pense que je suis un extraterrestre
c'est vrai marqué quand vous êtes arrivé
tout à l'heure je pensais sa
vision ans mais là vous dit juste
l'averse d'accord
vous avez dit que la nouvelle vague
avait démontré que finalement tout le
monde pouvait faire des signes et que
c'est peut-être pas bien d'ailleurs
enfin cela démontre le résultat est pas
terrible remarqué parce que le lendemain
on nous a cru on vous a pris
l'influent quand vous appris au monde
alors parlé de quelques réalisateurs
parce que vous êtes un des rares
finalement à notre époque et très peu de
gens comme ça qu'ils disent des choses
dans les médias les gens disent tous la
même chose vous savez très bien et il ya
très peu de gens alors il y avait des
alliés enfin je vais y aller quand
j'étais petite élise est plein de trucs
comme ça je te lâchement content vous
chauffage d link a vu que vous vous osez
dire des choses alors par exemple
n'avait pas du tout c'est eva spielberg
pourquoi
parce qu'ils pensent qu'ils aient un
meilleur metteur en scène qu'il n'est
élu cassé
on le casse est encore pire ceci dit
ceci dit c'est un bricoleur et vous avez
un ingénieur plus tôt mais tout ce qui
me
met par les robots darty est infiniment
supérieur à george lucas est responsable
j'adore
et chimie nof dit qu'il met le pognon
dans le dans les limousines mais tous
les films tous les grands films
américains pour
mettre l'argent dans les limousines qui
amène les acteurs sur place et vous
allez sur un tournage d'un grand film
américain vous voyez 40 chauffeur qui du
reste arrête at elle été moeurs et
cuisses et tout ça n'est que l'argent
mal acquis sont syndiqués à la mafia il
se tourne et fellini
pas mal comme c'est un
drame c'est un homme de cirque
mais il ya un épisode qu'on connaît pas
ces lignes et a commencé avec rossellini
ou aidant un des premier numéro des
cahiers je me souviens ça m'avait
beaucoup impressionné il a joué dans à
mort etc et m il s'appelle le miracle
histoire d'une femme qui croit être
enceinte d'un ange qui était jouée par
anna magnani
alors qu'elle avait juste été violée par
un magnifique jouet frederico fellini il
racontait son expérience et hier c'est
merveilleux le cinéma je sais pas
c'était comme ça on arrive on fait rien
on dit vouloir un sandwich aussitôt
qu'elle soit à la main tendue et les
jeunes voudraient un verre de champagne
en bas je vais continuer exactement
c'est tout ce que j'aime aussi dans ce
métier et kubrick je respecte on le
respecte parce qu'il est méticuleux
woody allen
je respecte parce qu'il est seul
vous n'êtes pas qu'ils aiment les salles
de montage parce qu'il fait chaud
il a lui fait et alors vous dites que
claude berri c'est moi même du vivier
oui mais si on lui dit je sais si vous
êtes sur lui pose du vivier à stains
meilleurs producteurs en fait d'une idée
ou ca - bon réalisateur louis mais il
est certain de gens que jamais il se
fâche me suis fâché à tous avec truffaut
quand je lui ai dit écoute
je trouve des films sont beaucoup moins
bien fait que les miens il vous manque
là par contre je suis beaucoup moins
bons scénaristes et à claude je lui dit
est infiniment meilleur producteur que
moi et il se fâche il vous montre le
fola
je dirais qu'il protège à sa manière
toujours et carax vous en parlera vous
vous en pensez quoi de carax
bajeux les chouettes du courage
besson
cb
c'est ça ben ouais pas mal
tout drôle de vous trouver ici dans
cette salle plébiscité par la profession
peut-être un peu tard
comme vous l'éternel marginale du cinéma
non ah bah oui mais vous savez la marge
c'est ce qui fait tenir les parents
semblent est ce que est ce que ce soir
jean luc godard on célèbre godard ou une
oeuvre
vous savez en
moi je crois que je fais des j'arrive
pas bien faire des films mais j'aime
bien faire du cinéma et je crois que
bon je remercie déjà les professionnels
de la profession d'avoir jeté à travers
moi le leur regard sur les amateurs
d'ombré lumière dont je fais partie pour
finir à une chose quand même qui a
changé chez vous c'est qu'avant vous
étiez moins comme ça on voyait moi la
télé raconte est tout simplement l'année
fort de parler comme ça ou c'est parce
que il faut le faire pour des raisons
commerciales ou simplement les la télé
c'est vers ça il faut le refus la versa
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu